mission impossible fallout is directed
by Christopher McQuarrie who also made
rogue nation and once again stars Tom
Cruise is Ethan Hunt Rebecca Ferguson
Simon Pegg ving rhames Henry Cavill and
Angela Bassett and tells the story of
Ethan hunts IMF team as they race
against time after a mission gone wrong
I've reviewed all the Mission Impossible
films in the past and I've always said
that this is one of my favorite action
franchises of all time and except for
the second film which was definitely the
weakest each one of them has been a very
impressive action film and each one of
them feels unique and different and
that's because all of them have had
different directors which is why I was
curious to see how fallout would fare
amongst the other since it is directed
by Christopher McQuarrie once again and
I'm very happy to say that Mission
Impossible fallout is here to make all
other action movies look like baby
movies I'm just gonna get right to the
point fallout is one of the best action
films I have ever seen
meticulously planned action sequences
not just from a choreography or stunts
perspective but from a cinematography
perspective there are so many
beautifully filmed moments I'm an action
movie junkie I love action films I
always have that's kind of why I'm more
hard on them than others I think I
expect more out of them and when it
comes to a movie like fallout we have a
star like Tom Cruise who's doing the
things that Ethan Hunt is written doing
in the script he's leaping over
buildings he's jumping from airplanes
he's hanging from helicopters he's
motorcycling through oncoming traffic in
Paris and it's the type of thing that a
lot of films would utilize CGI or
green-screen or a stunt double with a
CGI head over the stunt doubles body of
the real actor and here the action
sequences are so intense and
white-knuckled because they're actually
taking place I haven't seen an action
film that I've enjoyed this much since
Mad Max fury road this is probably my
favorite of the past few years it's just
a wonderfully executed action film from
beginning to end filled with set pieces
that are designed to make your jaw drop
and I've seen a lot and they're going to
because they did it there's a helicopter
sequence that is so thrilling I didn't
want it to end I could have watched
another half an hour of this sequence
every single action scene in the film
whether it's a foot chase or shootouts
some big stunt sequence with a
helicopter it's all the best version of
that that they could have done the best
running foot chase they could have made
the best motorcycle chase they could
have made it's hard to really understand
how they could possibly top this to be
honest and I feel like this film is
going to be the action movie to beat for
a while this is the sixth film and
despite the fact that I am a massive fan
of the first and the fourth in
particular I think this might be the
best and I've only seen it once I need
to see it again so the action sequences
are incredible but how is the story this
is where I can see some people having an
issue because it is one of those stories
similar to the first Mission Impossible
where you do have to pay attention to
just about every single line of dialogue
to follow it for some people that could
be a flaw and that's fine for me I love
that I love a film especially a summer
blockbuster that treats you with respect
that treats you like an adult and says
hey pay attention listen these lines
mean something these scenes are
important this isn't just mindless
entertainment this is meant to fuel a
story and I like how this film despite
its summer blockbuster trappings is
actually an action film for adults that
asks you to think about its plot and pay
attention as far as the antagonists in
this film I would say they're my
favorite since Philip Seymour Hoffman
and mi3 they're very strong the Mission
Impossible series has had a hard time
with villains before having ones that
are serviceable to the plot but not
necessarily memorable this film has some
very memorable ones I loved all the
supporting characters as well Simon Pegg
as usual is very entertaining Rebecca
Ferguson is terrific and this is
probably the best I've seen Henry Cavill
speaking of stunt work he has a fight
scene in a bathroom with Tom Cruise and
some other guys that's one of my
favorite fight scenes I've ever seen
it's brutal the punches feel so real
it's fast it's beautifully filmed with
these wide angles it was just everything
that I want an action film to be I was
sitting there constantly in my head
saying thank you thank you you you're
doing it thank you dear God thank you so
much this is exactly what I wanted if
you're a fan of Tom Cruise this movie
has like the ultimate Tom Cruise shot on
top of a building as he's running the
camera is like spinning around him and
it ends in the
incredible stunts that people in the
theater like shouted oh my god like and
in unison it was a beautiful thing I'm
also a big fan of the Mission Impossible
scores I pay attention to those quite a
bit I love what Michael Giacchino did
with three and four and obviously what
Danny Elfman did with the first film
Hans Zimmer strangely has the weakest
score of all of them although his is not
bad it had a very drum and bass like
feel for the early 2000s but he had some
really great choral arrangements in that
soundtrack but here we have Lorin ball
taking over at work as the composer and
I've listened to the soundtrack over the
past day and I think he did a great job
although it does feel a little
conventional in regards to like Bois
sounds every once in a while it really
worked in the film fallout could be
criticized as having recycled other
stories from other films I mean there's
a nuclear sub plot and someone who wants
to you know obtain things that could
possibly end the world and it's it's all
terrible and we've seen this many times
before and I would say that's probably
the weakest element of the film is that
it doesn't necessarily feel like a story
we've not seen before it doesn't feel
particularly fresh but the directing and
the way McQuarrie who also wrote the
film shifts the characters around and
uses this team to build tension in every
small way that he can whether ving
rhames is trying to defuse something but
he doesn't have enough hands to get the
job done and he has to call someone over
to him who isn't necessarily familiar
with us to help or Simon Pegg being in a
room filled with a bunch of boxes and
what he needs is in one of the boxes and
he has to search all of them McCrory
took the characters and he places them
in scenarios that constantly tests their
ability to do their job and that's why
it's mission impossible and from a
writing perspective that's brilliant
you're constantly on edge every scene is
either a turnaround or some sort of
twist or a surprise or you put a
character in a scenario where he or she
just can't figure it out or it's an
incredible action set piece Mission
Impossible fallout is everything I could
possibly want from an mi movie and it's
one of my favorite action films I've
ever seen I'm gonna give it an A please
see it in IMAX it's worth it you're
going to get more of an image on the top
and the bottom it's going to be
incredible please do see this one
I would love to see more in my films
although I don't know how they're going
to top this this is gonna be the action
film to beat I think for a while please
do check it out guys thank you so much
as always for watching and if you like
this you can click right here and get
stuck mine eyes
[Music]